In this problem, we're given an
urn with n balls in it, out
of which m balls
are red balls.
To visualize it, we can draw a
box that represents the set of
all n balls.
Somewhere in the middle or
somewhere else we have a cut,
such that to the left we have
all the red balls (there are
m), and non-red balls.
Let's for now call
it black balls.
That is n minus m.
Now, from this box, we are to
draw k balls, and we'd like to
know the probability that
i out of those k
balls are red balls.
For the rest of the problem,
we'll refer to this
probability as p-r, where r
stands for the red balls.
So from this picture, we know
that we're going to draw a
subset of the balls, such that
i of them are red, and the
remaining k minus i are black.
And we'll like to know what is
the probability that this
event would occur.
To start, we define our sample
space, omega, as the set of
all ways to draw k balls
out of n balls.
We found a simple counting
argument -- we know that size
of our sample space has
n-choose-k, which is the total
number of ways to draw k
balls out of n balls.
Next, we'd like to know how
many of those samples
correspond to the event that
we're interested in.
In particular, we would like to
know c, which is equal to
the number of ways to get
i red balls after
we draw the k balls.
To do so, we'll break c into
a product of two numbers --
let's call it a times b --
where a is the total number of
ways to select i red balls out
of m red balls.
So the number of ways to get
i out of m red balls.
Going back to the picture, this
corresponds to the total
number of ways to
get these balls.
And similarly, we define b as
the total number of ways to
get the remaining k minus i
balls out of the set n minus m
black balls.
This corresponds to the total
number of ways to select the
subset right here in the
right side of the box.
Now as you can see, once we have
a and b, we multiply them
together, and this yields
the total number of ways
to get i red balls.
To compute what these numbers
are, we see that a is equal to
m-choose-i number of ways to
get i red balls, and b is n
minus m, the total number of
black balls, choose k minus i,
the balls that are not red
within those k balls.
Now putting everything back, we
have p-r, the probability
we set out to compute, is equal
to c, the size of the
event, divided by the size of
the entire sample space.
From the previous calculations,
we know that c
is equal to a times b, which
is then equal to m-choose-i
times (n minus m)-choose-(k
minus i).
And on the denominator, we have
the entire sample space
is a size n-choose-k.
And that completes
our derivation.
Now let's look at a numerical
example of this problem.
Here, let's say we have
a deck of 52 cards.
And we draw a box with n equals
52, out of which we
know that there are 4 aces.
So we'll call these the left
side of the box, which is we
have m equals 4 aces.
Now if we were to draw
seven cards--
call it k equal to 7--
and we'd like to know what is
the probability that out of
the 7 cards, we have 3 aces.
Using the notation we did
earlier, if we were to draw a
circle representing the seven
cards, we want to know what is
the probability that we have 3
aces in the left side of the
box and 4 non-aces for the
remainder of the deck.
In particular, we'll
call i equal to 3.
So by this point, we've cast the
problem of drawing cards
from the deck in the same way
as we did earlier of drawing
balls from an urn.
And from the expression right
here, which we computed
earlier, we can readily compute
the probability of
having 3 aces.
In particular, we just have to
substitute into the expression
right here the value of m equal
to 4, n equal to 52, k
equal to 7, finally,
i equal to 3.
So we have 4-choose-3 times n
minus m, in this case would be
48, choose k minus i, will be 4,
and on the denominator, we
have 52 total number of cards,
choosing 7 cards.
That gives us [the]
numerical answer [for]
the probability of getting 3
aces when we draw 7 cards.